ATTEMPT TO MISLEAD THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> I JUST OFF A KOL WITH MY
COLLEAGUES.
WE’RE COMMITTED TO STAYING HERE
UNTIL WE HAVE AN AGREEMENT.
AN AGREEMENT THAT MEETS THE
NEEDS OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Sandra: HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY
PELOSI THERE PUTTING LAWMAKERS
ON NOTICE SAYING THEY WILL STAY
PUT IN THE NATION’S CAPITOL
UNTIL A CORONAVIRUS RELIEF BILL
IS REACHED.
PELOSI IS STILL NOT WILLING TO
BUDGE ON THE 2.2 TRILLION
DOLLAR PACKAGE.
REPUBLICANS HAVE SAID THAT
PRICE TAG IS A NON-STARTER.
WHERE DOES THAT LEAVE US?
CHAD PERGRAM IS LIVE ON CAPITOL
HILL WITH MORE.
GOOD MORNING.
CHAD.
>> GOOD MORNING.
THERE IS NO NEW TALKS SCHEDULED.
NOTHING IS REALLY CHANGING HERE.
WE’RE AT STATUS QUO AND THIS IS
WHAT IS STARTING TO WORRY RANK
AND FILE DEMOCRATS, ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO ARE MODERATES AND
FLIPPED DISTRICTS FROM RED TO
BLUE IN 2018.
THEY WANT TO GET SOMETHING DONE
AND THEY’RE GETTING IN THE EAR
OF THE DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP
INCLUDING MAX ROSE, A FRESHMAN
FROM NEW YORK CITY.
>> WE HAVE ALLEGIANCE TO OUR
COUNTRY.
WE DO NOT HAVE ALLEGIANCE TO
OUR PARTY LEADERS.
>> HAKEEM JEFFRIES SAYS MEMBERS
WANT TO STAY IN WASHINGTON
>> THE OVERWHELMING CONSENSUS
AMONG THE MEMBERS IS WE STICK
AROUND UNTIL WE GET SOMETHING
DONE FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> IT WON’T WORK THAT WAY.
THE HOUSE IS HERE FOR TWO WEEKS
TO DEAL WITH UNRELATED BILLS.
STENY HOYER REITERATED MEMBERS
WILL BE ON 24-HOUR NOTICE TO
RETURN TO WASHINGTON IF THERE
WAS A A CORONAVIRUS AGREEMENT.
BUT THE LAST THING THAT LEADERS
WILL DO IS KEEP MEMBERS WAITING
AROUND ON CAPITOL HILL DURING A
PANDEMIC JUST BEFORE THE
ELECTION WITHOUT A BILL.
THAT MAKES MEMBERS CRANKY.
THEY’RE ALREADY CRANKY ABOUT NO
DEAL.
>> THE PRESSURES ARE MOUNTING.
WHEN WE GO HOME AND TALK TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND THEY ARE
TELLING US HEARTBREAKING
STORIES OF HAVING ELECTRICITY
CUT OFF OR HAVING TO MOVE OUT
OF THEIR HOME AND STANDING IN
FOOD LINES, THOSE STORIES ARE
HEARTBREAKING.
>> IT’S UNCLEAR IF ANYTHING
COULD PASS THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES RIGHT NOW AS WE
ALWAYS SAY ON CAPITOL HILL, IT
IS ABOUT THE MATH, IT’S ABOUT
THE MATH.
THERE IS SOME CHATTER RIGHT NOW
ABOUT TRYING TO DO INDIVIDUAL
BILLS.
IT IS UNCLEAR IF ANY OF THOSE
CAN PASS.
SANDRA.
>> Sandra: I GUESS WE’LL HAVE
TO KEEP ON WATCHING WHERE THIS